quando sono arrivato in azienda
tanto tempo fa la prima cosa che ho
visto è una sorta di scatola misteriosa
in cui qualcosa entrava e da cui
qualcosa vicino ma soprattutto
all'interno della quale qual cosa
accadeva
certo era qualche generazione di
computer fa quella radio computer di
qualche tempo fa sono un po più grande
di voi ma soprattutto qualche
generazione di capelli fa di questi
erano i capelli di qualche tempo fa vi
saluto e in quel momento mi sono davvero
resoconto quali fossero le regole del
gioco soprattutto quelle non scritte
perché è lì che mi sono reso conto che
al di là dei conti economici delle
logiche produttive delle logiche
industriali dei bilanci ogni realtà
aziendale poggia in modo consapevole o
meno su alcuni punti cardinali di
riferimento che sono i propri valori
ed è proprio di valori che parleremo
oggi perché ci chiediamo quanto contano
davvero i valori oggi per competere
quanto possono incidere nel modo di fare
business se guardiamo la classifica
mostra my air company 2015 ai primi
posti troviamo aziende notissime come
apple google amazon e via dicendo
oppure ancora la classifica del world
mons dal brand di forbes anche qua apple
microsoft google coca cola che cosa
hanno in comune tra di loro queste
aziende al di là del fatto che sono tra
le più note al mondo
semplice un solido sistema di valori
condiviso a cui tutti i collaboratori
fanno riferimento si tratta di pilastri
che consentono alle persone di gestire
l'azienda linus con uno stile di
management che consente di avere davvero
a bordo le persone e che peraltro
consente di competere in modo più
efficace
non serve però andare così lontano da
noi a trovare esempi interessanti
infatti se decidiamo di mettere a fuoco
le giuste cose si scopre che è molto più
vicino di quanto si pensi si possono
trovare i giusti messaggi per quello
oggi mi piace condividere un breve
documento di 80 anni fa il 28 ottobre
1935 a campodarsego
immaginate un piccolo paese della
provincia nord di padova un imprenditore
nel consigliare una macchina scrive di
suo pugno la seminatrice vendute vi è
garantita per due anni tanto da difetti
di materiale di costruzione come da
qualsiasi difetto di funzionamento
in fede giovanni chi lo farebbe oggi
lui ci mette la faccia è lui stesso che
garantisce prodotto e servizio
e nel farlo da un fortissimo messaggio
tanto i propri clienti
quanto ai propri collaboratori
certo siamo in un periodo storico
completamente diverso
siamo in un piccolo paese si tratta di
un mondo in cui la relazione tra le
persone dentro e fuori l'azienda conta
più di ogni altra cosa un mondo in cui i
valori non condivisi perché sono scritti
o codificati ma condivisi nella
prossimità vengono vissuti nella
prossimità e arrivano quasi per una
sorta di osmosi valoriale a tutti i
livelli 1935 ovviamente l'azienda cresce
e cambia cambia dei linguaggi cambio
nelle persone cambia nelle strutture e
soprattutto cambia nelle logiche
nelle dinamiche ed è proprio qui che
diventano determinanti i valori perché
si possono creare dei ghetti che a volte
possono essere difficili da colmare
quando ho cercato un immagine che
potesse venne riassumere velocemente il
significato la natura di tali valori ben
venuto in mente un materiale non usuali
in ambito di management e chi fa
consulenza non sa benissimo che non si
usa da malta malta la cui funzione
principale non è tanto quella di
incollare le componenti tra di loro
quanto quella di distribuire il carico e
ricompensare le asperità fantastico
questo non ci fa venire in mente le
nostre organizzazioni i nostri bisogni
e allora vediamo quale malta usano le
aziende di maggior successo ovvero quali
sono i loro valori di riferimento quasi
sempre si parla di creazione di valore
ancora di innovazione ho sempre più in
un mondo che cambia in cui la
responsabilità diventa determinante
proprio di responsabilità a tutti i
livelli
dentro e fuori l'azienda con la catena
estesa del valore ma soprattutto
trasversalmente si parla di persone e
parliamo dunque di persone
facciamolo con un semplice semplicissimo
grafico tipicamente in azienda per
produrre si acquistano impianti con un
costo iniziale importante ed un valore
che nel tempo è destinato a scendere
anche si svalutano è normale per le
risorse umane idealmente il percorso
dovrebbe essere qualcosa di parallelo
distinto e soprattutto posto perché una
persona entra in azienda senza alcuna
competenza pratica e poi via via
acquisisce ricchezza incrementando le
proprie conoscenze e se per gli impianti
io mi adopero nel cambiare i pezzi
nell'investire nel fare manutenzione
insomma nel far di tutto per prolungare
il ciclo di vita di ogni macchina per
garantire la produttività così anche per
le persone è fondamentale pensare ad un
investimento a un sostegno ma è di euro
che stiamo parlando è di soldi e di
rilancio economico è di remunerazione se
pensiamo che viene via che passa il
tempo la soluzione sia sempre a quello
di rilanciare sul mero piano economico
avremo gioco forza che fare con
mercenari più interessati al premio che
il risultato ci interessa davvero questo
piuttosto con questo concludo
focalizziamoci su due parole chiave
la prima ascolto per le macchine esiste
la diagnosi la diagnostica per capire
come stanno nel tempo per le persone
fondamentale un ascolto consapevole
facciamogli capire che sono guardate
ascoltate e valutate e aca loro sono
riconosciuti i meriti lungo il percorso
e poi manutenzione nell'acquisto di una
macchina di un impianto è compreso un
programma di manutenzione
certo ma per le persone
anche qui è fondamentale impostare un
programma serio di accompagnamento
formativo che vada ben oltre alle
nozioni tecniche che non sono quelle che
si risolvono i problemi persone
ascoltate e manutentate saranno ben
liete di appartenere l'azienda e le
daranno indietro valore
lungo periodo poniamo dunque la persona
al centro è questo il grande valore dei
valori grazie